isolated just the two players there's
nothing that vincent company's got that
virgil van dijk hasn't got pace uh for
the leadership person if he's on another
level i would say that i don't think
that i don't think that's even being
biased i think the guy speaks five
languages he literally i mean he's a
rosetta stone
that certainly helps if it's accompanies
an app virgil speaks a couple of
languages but it doesn't mean he's a
better leader
i didn't mind good
yeah looking forward to this
it's going to be fun isn't it
it depends
on city will never be considered a big
club
three
two
one
i mean that's literally nonsense
it just is nonsense by every metric what
is what is your definition of a big club
a club that all the best players many of
the best players in the world want to
play for and win trophies and
uh get to the latter stages of the
competition yeah you can talk about
history and we'll that comes with time
like the city over the past ten years
one of the successful clubs in the in
the premier league uh if not the most
successful club in the premier league
over the past 10 years and you're
telling me another 20 30 years of that
which is very possible i'm not saying it
will happen but it's possible are you
telling me then that this club won't
grow and grow and grow no we don't have
the biggest fan base i'm aware of that
compared to maybe liverpool i've had
decades of dominance
your argument would be that you have
decades of it but why would manchester
city never ever be that can you
categorically say that man city will
never carry on in the same path that got
united and liverpool wherever you are
with the reputation to say that is my
gender i would say it's stupid
when it comes to the biggest clubs i'm
so i'm looking at five in the premier
league it's liverpool and manchester
manchester united i don't think that's
debatable you are the smaller club in
manchester
germany's by munich italy's probably
juventus slash ac milan and barcelona
real madrid so he's only five big five
to six if you're including but i mean
it's nice it's not a bit harsh and i
accidentally you know i mean like
because you're making your rules on the
rules there and then just you are
immediately writing off the club you've
got more european trophies than most
clubs no no i'm not writing them off i'm
just saying for me they're the elite
clubs they're they're the elite clubs
you've got a few big clubs as well like
your is in my opinion you guys aren't
going to get to that standard because
one the premier league is stupid do you
decide this standard by the way like why
is that the boundary like what was the
question again exactly the question is
will you become a big club yeah it's not
an elite club by
you may be a successful club but you'll
be seen as a big club because of how
you've accumulated your success
do you think fans and players are going
to care about that yes no well probably
yes they're not going to mate let's be
honest but
all right that's the case then why are
we not so do you consider chelsea a
massive club then yes they are all right
in what sense in fact they win loads of
trophies they're massive around the
world and all the best players want to
play for them how can anyone say
genuinely they are not a huge club i
mean look at the players they've had
over the issue some of the best of all
time great premier league players 15
years how long's football been going so
what it's like
so what that is the point yeah one point
man united weren't that one point
liverpool were in that where we have to
become was that when were we not that
point like 30 years ago 30 years exactly
30 years we were in a big club you
weren't as big as you are now of course
we were you take were you that round
then were we around it where where where
you guys the last 30 years exactly we'll
be the
all about okay like it's it's all i was
there for what it's worth so i was like
and what i say is it's just time your
metric is literally time that is it and
to say that you can't follow that same
time route is it's it's i would honestly
say it's a little bit short side i don't
know why you want to say that but look
liverpool are clearly a vehicle
manchester city i'm not arguing that
they are and that's humility for you
there but the idea that manchester city
look look i walk around manchester i've
lived here in my life i'm 35 years old
there's more kids knowing manchester
city shirts than it ever was to and that
is what reason because you've been
successful but that's exactly that's
fair enough and how does that develop
and keep going and going and eventually
the city stay at that level win more
trophies and eventually city will and
maybe it's because of the money and the
facility resources we've got they will
eventually when the champions league
eventually it'll happen and then
eventually no one cares what happened 40
years ago eventually you're just you
don't care what happened 40 years ago
there are millions of fans i do it's
football even at this stage and again
i'm not even trying to take dick but
even at this stage you still can't even
fill your stadium so you've had an
audience
so you've been successful since what 11
12 so almost 10 years of success right
and now you're still going through your
stage
because we haven't got you haven't got
years and years of overseas fans you
know you come over precisely so how
that's how
exactly so how all of a sudden are you
going to start getting more overseas
fans
you don't need more though
why you need more to be a super club
that players want to play for you might
have you might why to what to say
right now what's to say in terms of in
terms of being the biggest club in in
not talking about that's not the biggest
club
in terms of being a big club then how
many bigger clubs are there in england
right now than yourselves i mean youtube
videos and i know chelsea and arsenal
united all got more fans in manchester
city probably because by the way of
success during the the 80s 90s and the
2000s
because like built and more fans that
takes time to do and it does but arsenal
didn't have that fan base they didn't
until you know wenger and chelsea didn't
have that fan base either he had a
little bit but one but it was very
comparable to manchester city and now
chelsea are massive around the world
days before yes it's grown all of our
fan bases have grown that's that's they
didn't they didn't tell you near the
level they did they did they still had a
strong enough so they managed to see how
the strong caught they have but they had
no success behind it so there was a
combination of offsets
you guys have got a call within your
city
that is it but it's growing but it is
growing is it going to grow more than
the others if you keep winning yes i
doubt it why because the others already
established they're they're going to win
choose their team but they're going to
win stuff as well you've just seen how
did you know that though
we're going to wrap this one up
pep is a better manager than plot
three
two
one
you're lucky there's no more tables
so here's the thing i think pep's a
great coach
great manager
but for me he doesn't touch clock and
the reason i say that is because you
look at the situations that guardiola
has been in
and you look at the situations klopp's
been in and i think you swap the two
managers around klopp still thrives and
guardiola doesn't survive
he does i think he's a fundamentally
good coach and i think the reason why i
would say about guardiola and i mean
this genuinely i think guardiola and i
think he'd be the same for club by the
way cop would spend that money if you
had in front of it all right no i agree
but
doesn't have to spend the money so this
is this
so let's just break it down the
nitty-gritty no one since guardiola has
been in a premiership has spent more
money than guardiola okay yeah in that
time you've won two premier leagues uh
three now is it thrilled
but no champions leagues no so in the
time that and again i'm just counting
major trophies and again i don't want to
disrespect their fa cup and league up i
don't believe that those cups should be
disrespected and i actually really
love them no i rate you guys for winning
those but if you talk about major
trophies you've won three klops one two
in the same time you spent half a
billion i think there's like a major
trophy is a mark on club i think it is
personally a lack of a lack of um
trophies in general other than just
going for the ones i think that's um
mark against them you probably disagree
but i think it is so it's a mark against
him but the reason why it's a mark is
because he doesn't have the squad death
that a manchester city or barcelona or a
buying machine he's been a few times
where he's definitely
he's definitely taken the easy option
out and played that card i think i mean
i mean that's true but we don't get
drawn with port vale and all these teams
every season either
it's never been it's not always easy can
you honestly hand on heart sit here and
tell me
pep takes over that liverpool team that
clock took over and takes them to the
heights that klopp's taking them to does
pep do that i don't know i honestly
don't know i think that's a fair answer
and i i guess the point i was making
before we didn't finish because i think
guardiola spends the money like
clockwork because it's there but i do
think we forget that fundamentally
guardiola is a great coach but then
given if you're giving the easy option
each time it doesn't matter who you are
guardiola myself you whatever and and
it's to spend loads of money and just go
out and buy a player you're going to
choose that that's because it's there in
front of you having said that i do
honestly believe that guardiola was told
he was at a club we just can't do that
you're gonna have to make do what you
did like you did last year by the way i
know we'll see if we still put a little
money but but no i mean you know the
player making it a hundred million yeah
the player making it the finish was
about to strike us and we said look you
have to make do and he had to find a
solution to put on making with the
strikers and he did find a solution once
again i know we're still blessed with
the squad that we've got but he found a
solution it was it was right coaching
the false line thing was a real it was
for him it was a relative it was a it
was a solution to a problem and i guess
the point i'm making is that if he had
to do that more often i think he would
because i think he's a good coach raheem
sterling made the right choice
three
two
one
i just look at the trophies
unfortunately mate and the new walters
one as well and
maybe he could have gone really well if
you say that's where but i i think even
he would he'd be right he was saying we
sat here he'd move up to there he'd be
actually saying can you extend it down
that's not true because when he left you
guys he said that if klopp would come in
sooner he wouldn't have left
he wasn't you know
she'd be my uncle
but that clearly shows he doesn't love
the club he's just gone there just to
pick up a few trophies and you'll bounce
he's not well he's been here for like
six years now he's getting there's
tweets he wants to bounce after many
many years of winning loads of trophies
and becoming a world superstar so i
think he's made the right cause what i'm
saying he was a superstar before you
bought him he made him that
little where he's now he's a bit
different he was he was a golden boy he
was i wouldn't say he was a he wasn't a
superstar in the sense that he's not
because he he wasn't like you know a guy
who had a ridiculous collection of
trophies and he wasn't you know he was
on his way to becoming a worldwide name
but he wasn't yet he was like the one
the bashing players in the premier
league definitely he was fantastic um
but um
yeah i just i can't i to honestly it's
simple this to me is he's just won an
awful lot and scored an awful lot of
goals and become one of the best players
in the world so the reason i've i've
gone with strongly agree for this one is
not because of trophies i just think at
a time when we had raheem sterling he
probably looked around the dressing room
and bar and coutinho he was the best
player in that team and he was only what
18 or 19. did you have as
um foreign don't begrudge sterling
philly how he did it i think could have
been handled differently what if he
doesn't make it out to be no no it's not
as bad as some people make out but i
mean
he didn't let liverpool did sleep well
he didn't go training or whatever as
well
so
is a better player than company ever was
three
two
one
i'm going to reason because i don't
think you could possibly prove it um
do you just be advised but to say no
yeah i think i think it's a yeah i rate
it i rate it i think that what i mean by
that is like it's just the video
companies are pregnant legend and right
now you can't i don't think you can say
that about van dyke that he has that i
think he needs a just back in five years
is what i'm saying that's fair i mean
that's because i think right now vandak
is a phenomenal player um but he's won a
friendly league in a champions league
i'm not saying this government that
could literally be it it might not be
but it could be and i think then we'd
turn around and say that this question
is very much a recent question and what
i mean by that is that
it feels like a fair thing now and it
could be a fair thing but i reckon it
could be that if if say and i don't i
don't know if this will happen or not
and just it's just a question if vandy
doesn't win anything else i don't think
people would necessarily aim clearly
better company i don't think they would
be saying that i think right now it
feels that way it could be that it's all
right so
to see and what time do we talk about if
we're looking at the two players and
again look i'm not going to sit here and
say anything bad about company company
literally phenomenally he was absolutely
brilliant but again i ask you
company did he really transform do you
want to 18 had to use against you
because of him
plus the goal with the goal yeah the
defense that that's what i got for 37
games yeah but he went on that 14-game
winning streak he was absolutely huge
for us he was 14 games no one dribbled
past van dijkin over a calendar year he
won the premier league trophy like who
cares about normal dribble passes we're
talking about them as players we're not
talking about the team yeah but that
that is insane brilliance that led to a
trophy is what i'm saying yeah and so
valentine's day
came in i'm not even going to mention
certain names of players we had we saw
how bad we were defensively he came in
and he shut all that out tonight look
what we've done
again i'm not going to sit here and say
he's clear of course with more trophies
that's what we'll say yes because he had
better players around him he had more
wealth and he's not cool
no i'm not saying it but i'm saying if
we're judging the two players isolated
just the two players there's nothing
that vincent company's got that virgil
van dyke hasn't got pace uh i have to
say leadership personally if he's on
another level i would say that i don't
know i don't think that i don't think
that's even being biased i think the guy
speaks five languages he literally i
mean he's a rosetta stone
that certainly helps her like if it's a
company as an app virgil speaks a couple
of languages but doesn't mean he's a
better leader i would just say if it's a
company it's i mean if you literally put
in a melting pot of attributes and
qualities to be a captain it would
literally produce but we don't talk
about being a captain if we talk about
defensive attributes what has van dyke
got that company has so what does a
company have that van dyke hasn't
there isn't one thing i would i would
generally say the leadership nobody all
right i think he's going through the
physical attributes i think virgil was
probably slightly ahead of company was
faster people realized he was as fast as
virgil though he's fast enough no one
ever ran past him morris green was fast
but you say bolton making is i know what
he didn't that extra pace didn't it's
not like it ever affected companies what
i would say because he was just faster
than fast he needed to be he caught up
to balmyang at like 32 you know so like
he was always fast enough he was fast as
a defender all right but virgil was
faster i think virgil's better in the
air again i don't agree with that person
but again i'm not and when i say this
i'm not trying to say this just to crap
on the company i don't know i know i'm
not saying it's not the same i think
he's better i think he's better at
everything
his important head is a company score
for us
like he just says they're attacking
headers the point is he's great in the
air and he was i just i think if it's a
company it was insane yeah it's
entertaining yeah i think i think virgil
van dyke you managed to get games as
well you released the big games in terms
of like the physical one-on-ones likes i
thought it worked by the way and one
people will say
all these kind of people to play against
like like i think he's played at van
persie he's played against more did he
drop both people out he's playing it's
more how old was drogba when he played
against drug breath
that might be true company's phenomenal
i'm nothing but respect for company
always respect him as a player i just
think van dyke is better i think he's
got more attributes i think his his
reign at liverpool is clouding people's
judgment on how good he was actually was
at southampton because southampton
wasn't under the microscope and the way
liverpool is he was brilliant at
southampton hence why he got the move to
liverpool what i will say is i'll
probably slightly downgrade this
disagree but i don't think i think it's
the wording of ever was i think that's i
think that's unfair from being honest um
i think people don't realize
how good physical companies make money
yeah he's a primary legend
cheers here's my phone now
i think scores is a better player than
steve i'm saying school's a phenomenal
player but he's not better than jerrod
as a whole as a club the only person
you'll go to man is steven jenner i
would be really disappointed that mighty
liverpool can't throw another name
and i'd be disappointed that you haven't
got one player who's better it's bad
i've got all the players multiple
players over the years of course who
bruno fernandez is better than right now
you are smoking stuff you shouldn't be
smoking
bruno fernandez yeah bruno fellaini's
bitten in gerard yeah go on based on
what